[Music]
take a look at all these faces more than
30 women have come forward publicly to
say that Harvey Weinstein sexually
harassed or assaulted them and now add
to that list model turned actress Angie
Everhart she is describing in detail
which she claims happened with the movie
mogul at the Venice Film Festival I wake
up and Harvey is standing above my bed
and then all of a sudden he takes his
pants down and starts and I hate
blocking the door ever Hart told an LA
radio-station Weinstein told her not to
tell anyone about the incident the Mogul
is in Arizona right now he had planned
to go to an inpatient treatment center
for sex addiction there but a source
tells us he will instead receive
treatment at a private Arizona residence
where therapists will come to him
meanwhile a lot of people are wondering
if Weinstein could be charged with a
crime at least 32 women have come
forward reportedly claiming they were
sexually harassed or assaulted by the
Mogul Rachel Stockman the editor in
chief of Law News says charges are
possible but there are a lot of factors
at play it's gonna depend on where it
happened when it happened and in of
course what state because different
states have different statute of
limitations Weinstein's attorney has
said any allegations of non-consensual
sex are unequivocally denied by mr.
Weinstein Oprah addressed the wine
themed scandal on face book writing I
believe a shift is coming many in
Hollywood agree it's a casting couch
town for a hundred years and that has to
it has to change I respect any woman
courage to come out and say this
happened to me and I don't want to
happen anybody else I hope that this
just stops happening it stops being okay
I was really glad that he's being held
accountable and more fallout for the
mobile Weinstein's name is being removed
from all of the weinstein companies TV
shows including Project Runway you will
however see Harvey's estranged wife
Georgina Chapman on Project Runway
all-stars the Marchesa co-founder is a
regular judge on the show a source tells
us she's currently looking for a divorce
attorney now just to be clear the new
season of Project Runway all-stars was
already taped before the scandal broke
and it will air next year
you